Loki's been an integral villain and eventual
anti-hero in the Marvel Cinematic Universe for
years. While he's made his mark in more obvious
ways, From inside jokes to crazy comic references,
here are the best Loki Easter eggs in the MCU.
After seemingly falling to his doom in Thor, Loki
reappears as the primary villain of The Avengers.
Or at least, he seems to be. He's actually
leading an invasion of Earth on behalf of Thanos,
laying the groundwork for Avengers:
Infinity War six years down the road.
Thanos relays his messages to Loki through
a hooded character called the Other,
who wants to make sure Loki understands
how seriously Thanos takes his mission.
"You think you know pain? He will make
you long for something sweet as pain."
While the Other delivers his menacing monologue,
a snake-like creature slithers
meaningfully in the background.
Loki doesn't need to be told twice. In the
real-life collection of Norse mythological
poems known as the Elder Edda, the gods
punish Loki for killing Odin's favorite son,
Baldur, by tying him to a rock with his own
kid's intestines while a snake hangs above him,
dripping venom onto his face.
Loki's wife, Sigyn, catches the toxins
in a basin, but every once in a while,
she has to leave to empty it, and the venom
falls on Loki's face so painfully that he
shakes the whole Earth. The snake in
Avengers may have been a reminder,
both to Loki and us, of just how
much pain he's endured in the past.
In the end of The Avengers, the heroes save
the day and capture Loki so Thor can extradite
him to his home in Asgard to face Odin's
justice. As Thor carries his brother away,
he's locked up not just with cuffs on
his wrist but a muzzle on his mouth.
That seems fitting for a character who
does so much damage with just his words,
and it's even more fitting when you
know a little about your mythology.
In medieval historian Snorri Sturluson's Younger
Edda, Loki thinks it'd be a good idea to shave all
of Sif's hair. When the other gods catch him,
Loki agrees to commission the dwarfs to make
Sif more hair out of gold. Loki offers to pay
with his own head, and the dwarfs get to work
making not just making a headdress for Sif but
also a spear for Odin and Thor's hammer, Mjolnir.
When it comes time to pay, Loki agrees, but he
reminds the dwarfs the deal is only for his head,
and if the dwarfs take off any of his
neck along with it, the bargain is void.
The dwarfs have no choice but to let Loki go,
but they still get back at him by sewing his
mouth shut to keep him from smooth-talking
anyone else again. Loki's muzzle in The
Avengers looks a lot less painful than
that, but the parallel should be clear.
In Thor: The Dark World, Thor and Loki
commandeer one of the Dark Elves' ships
from the Asgardian impound. As Thor and Loki flee
Asgard, Thor sideswipes one of Asgard's monuments.
"Well done, you've just
decapitated your grandfather."
It's a brief throwaway line, but comics
fans may recognize its deeper significance.
In 2009's Thor #600, Thor really does kill his
own grandfather — thanks to Loki, of course. The
god of mischief travels thousands of years into
the past to trap the soul of Thor's grandfather,
Bor, in the snow, then returns to resurrect
him ... but not before scrambling Bor's
mind so he'll attack everything in sight. As
Bor rampages through New York, Thor finally
realizes there's no way to stop him except by
killing him — all according to Loki's plan,
since the penalty for killing
Asgardian royalty is exile.
Marvel loves sneaking in Easter eggs so much
that they're not content to stop with the movies.
Even the tracklist to Thor: The Dark World
manages to squeeze in a reference that goes
back beyond Loki's comic book history to the
original Norse texts. Composer Brian Tyler
includes Loki's theme on the album, named
"Lokasenna." It may seem like a bunch of
random letters attached to Loki's name at first
glance, but it actually comes from one of the
earliest surviving references to the character,
an Old Norse poem collected in the Elder Edda.
Even in the Middle Ages, the Loki we know and
love was already fully formed. The poem tells
of him getting kicked out of a party
for killing another one of the guests,
then returning to pick fights with other gods and
accusing them of all kinds of crimes. Finally,
Loki politely excuses himself when Thor
threatens to shut him up with his hammer.
The end of The Dark World reveals that Loki
didn't actually die in his battle with the
Dark Elves. In fact, the Odin that Thor has been
asking permission to return to Earth is actually
Loki in disguise. So, when Thor returns from
his journeys across the universe in search of
the Infinity Stones in Thor: Ragnarok, he gets
to see what Loki has been up to in his absence.
Still pretending to be Odin, Loki is putting on a
play that tells the story of his supposed heroic
death, with Chris Hemsworth's brother,
Luke, as Thor and Matt Damon as Loki.
Before we see what's going on, we get a brief
look at the stage itself as Thor flies over the
Asgardian skyline. The design fits the vanity
of the whole project — the whole thing's a
gigantic recreation of Loki's own golden
helmet with its distinctive curved horns.
In Thor: Ragnarok, Loki's self-congratulatory play
proves that he's probably better off sticking with
supervillainy than writing. As Matt Damon plays
Loki's drawn-out death scene, he uses his last
words to atone for all his regrets, including
the events of The Avengers — and another thing.
"Sorry about that time I turned you into a frog."
Surely something that silly couldn't have been
an actual story in the comics, could it? Well,
in the '80s, writer-artist Walt Simonson took the
reins of Thor with an appropriately grandiose,
mythic take on the character, one full of new
worlds, epic battles, and poignant deaths.
But he wasn't above a little change
of pace to lighten things up a bit.
In Thor #364, Loki's latest power
play involves transforming his brother
into an amphibian. Thor doesn't let that stand
in the way of his heroism, though, and he aids
a colony of Central Park frogs in their war
against the rats before returning to Asgard.
Thor: Ragnarok takes a much more lighthearted
approach towards the apocalypse than Norse
mythology does, but the film does deliver on the
destruction of Asgard. Toward the end of the film,
things look grim for our heroes. But that's
when Loki shows up in a massive ship,
accompanied by warriors. As Asgardian refugees
flee Hela and seek refuge on Loki's new ship,
the god of mischief welcomes them aboard.
Interestingly, the Younger Edda also says Loki
will arrive at Ragnarok at the helm of a ship,
In Norse mythology, Loki comes bringing
destruction instead of salvation, but Thor:
Ragnarok's writer-director, Taika Waititi,
cleverly flips the script to suit his more
sympathetic interpretation of the character.
Check out one of our newest videos
right here! Plus, even more Looper
videos about your favorite comic book
heroes and villains are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.